Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 just came out James Gunn has
been revealing all kinds of deleted scenes in
Easter eggs one of the biggest is annihilus
who's a huge Fantastic Four villain and part of
the annihilation story that inspired part of the
plot of the movie so we'll break it all down and
some of the other cool Easter eggs and deleted
scenes he just revealed if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're still doing that special giveaway
for the Guardians of the Galaxy video game so
I'll name another winner later in the video and
careful for spoilers for the movie if you haven't
seen it yet but James Gunn just revealed that
originally a nihilus was going to be the main
villain of the movie and he would have been
the person who created rocket it would have
required a huge plot change and set a nihilus
up as a much bigger overarching Thanos level
threat kind of like Kang the Conqueror a nihilus
was originally A Fantastic Four villain from the
negative zone They explored the Negative Zone
during the 2015 Fantastic Four movie it's meant
to be kind of like an alternate dimension
of pure anti-matter energy a nihilus is
a bug-like creature who evolved accidentally
from an an insect in a mutation gave him high
intelligence he gained the knowledge of the race
that created him accidentally and then acquires
the cosmic control rod in the negative Zone which
allows him to manipulate cosmic energy at a super
high level and he uses that to conquer that
Dimension Reed Richards discovers the Negative
Zone The Fantastic Four start exploring it running
into him over the years they defeat him multiple
times they even stole the cosmic control
rod from him to heal Sue Richards one time
going to rip our Dimension apart you you have to
give it up let us take it back to the negative
zone so the Fantastic Four are really the only
threat that anilas fears but he tries to invade
Earth multiple times Crossing Dimensions different
ways with his army each time he is defeated by The
Fantastic Four sometimes with the help of other
Marvel crossover characters like The Avengers the
Thor characters the original Captain Marvel even
Agatha Harkness that's right Agatha the Harkness
is a huge Fantastic Four character originally
the connection there is that she was Franklin
Richards nanny for a while you tried telling a 10
year old that his mother is cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs
I promise I won't bite I actually did bite a kid
once I'm guessing Franklin Richards was probably
not the kid that she wound up biting because you
don't want to bite Franklin Richards he's like
one of the most powerful characters that Marvel
has ever created for example Galactus becomes the
herald of Franklin Richards we know Marvel's
going to do the MCU version of Fantastic Four
they're about ready to officially announce the
cast they're probably gonna wait till Comic-Con
to do that even though it sounds like Adam Driver
has been confirmed as the new Reed Richards the
rest of the Fantastic Four will be announced
by later this year the connection between a
nihilist and the Guardians of the Galaxy is the
annihilation storyline in the sequel to that event
Annihilation Conquest so during Annihilation
annihilus invades the regular Universe with
his army the annihilation wave after he discovers
the Negative Zone version of the power Cosmic the
force that Galactus wields giving him a huge power
upgrade he tries to take out Galactus and capture
all of his Heralds like terrax the Silver Surfer
to take the power Cosmic as his own they wind up
helping defeat annihilus with the other crossover
characters like the other big characters including
Nova Phila Vel Quasar who does appear in this
movie and joins the team for a while then by the
events of the sequel Annihilation Conquest that
Guardians of the Galaxy Roster Has Come Together
as the version of the MCU team that we've seen
in all the Guardians movies by the end of all
this Adam Warlock by Lavelle are both on the
team as they are in Guardians of the Galaxy 3
but the main villain of the sequel event winds up
being Ultron who takes control of the Phalanx Army
a race of technological beings the universe had
been weakened by its fight against the nihilist
during the annihilation event and he uses that
to his advantage to try and take over himself
that was meant to explain what happened to Ultron
after the Avengers fire his body into deep space
it would have been like what happened to Ultron
after the events of Avengers Age of Ultron but
in the MCU they've changed that storyline and
they're bringing Ultron back during the Iron
Man armor Awards movie but even though they had
planned to use the nihilus in the Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 movie and they're changing a lot of
the Ultron plot from Annihilation Conquest even
had they included all that stuff in Guardians
3 they still would have had to have been a lot
of changes because undialist doesn't have any real
connection with rocket in the comics so making him
Rocket's Creator as James Gunn said he would have
done would have been another big change the entire
point of the movie like the main plot was meant
to be Rocket's origin story he'd always planned
on telling that story and in the comics High
evolutionary also did not create him so that would
have been another big change originally the group
that created him were called the game masters of
half World there is an Easter egg for that in the
first Guardians of the Galaxy movie during their
prison lineup based on the way Rocket's origin
goes down in the MCU now I think this means that
he fled to half world after he escaped the high
evolutionary and they just grew to adulthood there
before he met Groot but you can see how they
were planning on turning a nihilus into a much
bigger character early on which a lot of you been
theorizing heading into Marvel Phase 6 and Beyond
post Thanos Avengers end game there's just a short
list of villains that everyone's been theorizing
are big enough or could become big enough to be
Thanos Level Threats and analyst is one of them
and even though they went with Kang and Avengers 5
will beat Kang Dynasty and then we're doing Secret
Wars a funny not so secret you probably heard
about is that Marvel didn't always plan for Kang
to be the main overarching villain of Marvel Phase
6 in Avengers 5. in fact if you go back a couple
years to around Avengers end game and you look
at what they were saying there was all this talk
and hype about the eternals and the celestials
and it was revealed at least originally before
the fox Disney buyout deal went through Marvel
had planned for all this Multiverse Saga Marvel
phase 4 Phase 5 phase six Avengers 5 Avengers 6 to
revolve around the eternals characters they were
meant to sort of be the replacement for Marvel
not being able to use the X-Men characters or
the Fantastic Four core characters and if you
remember James Gunn had finished writing the
script for Guardians of the Galaxy 3 during 2018
before Avengers end game came out when Marvel was
still planning a completely different plot line
through Avengers 5 and Avengers 6 but then James
Gunn was fired the movie sat around for years
they finally released it in 2023 during Marvel
Phase 5 with some changes so it sounds like early
on when the movie was still going to be released
early in Marvel phase 4 they had planned to set
up a nihilus as a a possible new main overarching
villain that they could use in Avengers 5. now we
all saw what wound up happening the Loki series
happened initially Marvel didn't plan on saying
Jonathan Majors was also really a king variant
just calling himself he who remains they actually
cast him for Loki only as he who remains that
was the original intention it wasn't until they
started writing Ant-Man of the WASP quantumania
deciding that they wanted King the Conqueror to
be the main Ville of that movie then they saw
Jonathan Majors auditions for the Loki series and
said oh what if we made these two characters the
same person or similar people and came up with the
whole concept of the Kang variants in the dynasty
of Kings so all the Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty plot
all the Kang variants was added on the Fly late in
the process after Marvel decided that they wanted
to use Kang as the next overarching Thanos level
villain so the whole idea is that early on Marvel
was just trying out a couple of different ideas
couple different villains and seeing which
ones stuck with audiences the most so there
is an alternate timeline where we would have seen
Avengers 5 Annihilation and then Secret Wars from
a lot of people that thought that Annihilation
would have been Avengers 5. there were a lot
of early theories about that a couple years
ago turns out you were more correct than you
might have known I think they'd always planned
on using Secret Wars for Avengers 6 though it
was just a question of who the villain of Avengers
5 would be let me know in the comments though if
you would have rather seen a nihilist become the
villain of Avengers 5. James Gunn also revealed
a bunch of other cool Easter eggs and details
he did confirm that there were no plans for a
Guardians of the Galaxy 4 movie but it did say
that Marvel let him pick Rocket's new Guardians
team with Adam Warlock philavel Quasar and Cosmo
and that he's spoken to them about the way they'd
use the Guardians team in future Marvel movies
he revealed another Pete Davison Cameo he was
one of the high evolutionaries servants he was
wearing a helmet the whole time so you wouldn't
have been able to recognize him or known it was
him unless they told you he was in James Gunn's
Suicide Squad movie that's the connection he's one
of the characters that they kill off hilariously
at the beginning of the movie there was also a
funny Peacemaker Cameo 2 in the background like
blink and you'll miss it it's a spin-off from the
DC movie too it's connected to that Suicide Squad
movie when rocket saves all the animals at the end
of the movie from the cages like the baby raccoons
all the other animals he said that the eagle in
the cage there is the actual eagerly from The
Peacemaker series like the pet that Peacemaker
keeps with him all the time make all the jokes
about a Marvel DC crossover that you want to
like high evolutionary Crossing between cinematic
universes to steal animals from the DC Universe
the funny thing about that too is that now that
James Gunn is the Kevin foggy of DC and he can
actually make that deal make the deal to do a
Marvel DC crossover he says there's this actually
been some discussion about that but not to expect
them to do a Marvel DC crossover movie for like
10 more years but that it could actually happen
now usually it involves a lot a lot of lawyers
agreeing to things in a room back to the MCU
the Marvel Universe James Gunn also talked about
the Thor character he said that he never had any
intention of addressing Thor anywhere in Guardians
of the Galaxy 3. originally you remember Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 would have been real least before
Thor love and thunder had he not been fired by
Marvel so originally that would have been the next
place where Thor had to show up with the Guardians
of the Galaxy the asgardians of the Galaxy they
would just address what happens to him before
the events of Thor love and thunder James Gunn
said that when he wrote the script for Guardians
3 he never addressed Thor during it at all and it
didn't change the script after he had been fired
like he finished the script the final version of
the script in 2018 so they would have just picked
up in Guardians 3 you would have never seen Thor
and you would have gotten a Thor love and thunder
not knowing what happened to the character in
reality he did get fired by Marvel Thor love
and thunder came out first in taikawatidi did that
as Guardians of the Galaxy Thor Guardians of the
Galaxy Crossover at the beginning of the movie
just to explain what happened to the character
next James Gunn was telling jokes about that too
like thank God taikova TD bit that bullet because
I never had any intention of addressing Thor
during my movie he also revealed that rocket has
not been in contact with Thor since the events
of Avengers end game we can blame that on the
incident with the goats connecting back to his
future DC movies James Gunn also said that some
of his actors from Guardians of the Galaxy 3 would
be in Superman Legacy which he's in the middle of
writing right now even though he's a writers
strike and the other upcoming DC movies that
he works on but he didn't say which actors and
he didn't say which characters in the DC movies
they'd be playing Michael Rooker would be a really
interesting Perry white if he ends up using him
because Michael Rooker is in pretty much all of
James Gunn's movies and if he does wind up using
Chris Pratt as a DC character I feel like Booster
Gold would be the best fit for him let me know in
the comments which Guardians actors do you want
to see in upcoming DC movies and who do you think
they should play congratulations Brandon Martinez
two five six four you're the giveaway winner from
my last big Guardians of the Galaxy video please
email me on the about page of my channel so I can
get your contact details everyone click here for
my full Guardians of the Galaxy 3 breakdown in
East race in the entire movie and click here for
my Guardians of the Galaxy 3 post credit scene
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next and!